bonjour à tous mardi dernier les
commissions des affaires étrangères et
du développement durable ont auditionné
Laurent Fabius le ministre des Affaires
étrangères a été entendu à propos de la
préparation de la conférence de Paris de
2015 sur le climat l'objectif de cette
conférence et bien c'est d'accélérer les
négociations et d'aboutir enfin un
nouvel accord universel sur le climat
Laurent Fabius a d'ailleurs estimé mardi
qu'il était essentiel d'arriver à un
accord ambitieux et un accord avec des
engagements en matière de réduction des
gaz à effet de serre cette réunion par
ailleurs sera placée sous le signe de
l'exemplarité puisque tout un plan
d'action est prévu pour réduire l'impact
environnemental de cette conférence tout
de suite donc retour à cette audition
qui s'est tenue mardi 6 mai au
Sénat bonjour à tous mes chers collègues
bonjour monsieur le ministre bienvenue
au Sénat donc ben je suis très heureux
sincèrement avec mon collègue donc
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères et les membres de cette
commission et les membres de la
commission du dévelement durable de vous
accueillir donc pour vous entendre sur
la préparation du de la conférence de
Paris 2015 sur le climat alors avant
cela je voulais simplement vous dire que
notre commission durable est la plus
jeune commission permanente du Sénat
elle a à peine 2 ans 2 ans un peu plus
de 2 ans d'existence mais dès sa
création elle s'est beaucoup intéressé
bien sûr à cette problématique vous
l'imaginez et nous avons d'ailleurs un
groupe qui s'est un petit peu spécialisé
dans les différents sommets qui ont eu
lieu et nous avons après le Sommet de
Copenhague participé au sommet de Rio ou
d'ailleurs nous avons assisté une
conférence du président François Holland
et de vous-même et nous avons évidemment
été un petit peu déçus mais ça nous en
parlerons tout à l'heure alors je
voudrais en profiter pour vous dire que
le le Sénat donc s'est intéressé déjà
depuis très longtemps donc à cette
problématique puisque il faut le
rappeler c'est en 2000 que Paul vergess
a créé l'observatoire national sur les
effets du réchauffement climatique la
fameuse onerc qui d'ailleurs donc en
relation avec tout ce qu'a pu produire
le GC a fourni des documents très
intéressants qui ont commencé à essayer
d'évaluer ce que coûterait si nous ne
faisons rien CEA ch climatique et
inversement ce que pourrait coûter une
action si nous commencions assez tôt
dans une forme de prise de conscience et
d'action alors le président de la
République et vous-même donc avez fixé
donc comme priorité pour ce sommet et
pour donc votre ministère bien sûr non
seulement évidemment de de l'organiser
mais bien sûr de le réussir et bien sûr
nous sommes tous derrière vous pour
essayer de contribuer donc à cette
réussite et c'est pour cela que nous
avons créé un groupe de travail pour
suivre donc ce sommet alors bien sûr ce
que nous souhaiterionion aujourd'hui
c'est bien sûr essayer de vous entendre
sur la préparation à quel stade en
est-on comment avez-vous mobilisé vos
service et l'entre réseau de la
diplomatie donc cette perspective
quelles sont selon vous aujourd'hui les
perspectives de parvenir à un accord
ambitieux lors de cette conférence et
enfin qu'attendez-vous du Sénat et des
sénateurs pour seout tenir votre
démarche et celle de la diplomatie
française voilà monsieur le ministre
nous avons donc devant nous 1 heure 1 he
et15 si vous voulez bien donc faire ce
point et ensuite vous verrez les
questions vont se déchaîner et nous
essaierons bien sûr d'y répondre voilà
Monsieur ministre merci beaucoup monur
pr collègue veut dire de mot ah je peux
faire oui le mot d'accueil puisque la
commission des affaires étrangères
accueille son ministre en quelque sorte
mais c'est vrai que le sujet euh qui
nous occupe aujourd'hui relève largement
de la commission du développement local
c'est vrai que l'actualité est plus
portée en matière d'affaires étrangères
du côté de l'Ukraine
ou ou du Sahel ou de centra-afrique mais
je constate pour paraphraser quelqu'un
qui fut célèbre et qui l'est toujours
que la maison brûle mais que vous ne
regardez pas ailleurs voilà en la
circonstance ce long processus
sur le changement climatique enclenché
déjà depuis fort longtemps peut vivre
une étape décisive l'année prochaine à
Paris nous souhaitons naturellement que
ça soit le cas merci beaucoup monsieur
les présidents ben mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs chers amis d'abord je vous
remercier de de m'accueillir aujourd'hui
dans cette maison que je connais et que
j'apprécie pour
évoquer un sujet extrêmement important
d'ordinaire quand je viens
devant vos commissions c'est pour parler
en général de politique étrangère mais
cette fois-ci c'est évidemment pour
parler de la 21e conférence des partis à
la Convention 4 des Nations Unies sur
les changements climatiques c'est son
nom complet mais
euh dans notre jargon commun euh nous
l'appelons la COP 21 où
aussi et je pense que c'est une
acception que vous ferez vutre Paris
climat 2015 puisque
cela se fera chez nous euh je ferai donc
quelques remarques introductives et
ensuite bien sûr je suis à votre entière
disposition sachant que les uns et les
autres vous êtes des spécialistes de ces
questions d'abord sur euh le degré
d'urgence et sur l'opportunité
d'agir les causes les manifestations les
conséquences sont bien connus de vous
dans les dernières publications du GC il
n'y a absolument aucune
ambiguité le changement climatique est
sans précédent
et l'influence des activités humaines
est incontestable d'ailleurs c'est une
remarque que je me permets de faire en
passant et que le vice-président algor
m'a fait lorsque nous trouvions ensemble
dans une réunion au début du mois de
janvier si l'on se rapporte à l'état
d'esprit qui existait dans l'opinion
publique y compris dit éclairé il y a
seulement deux ou 3 ans il y a un
changement considérable car quasiment
plus personne ne conteste d'une part la
gravité du phénomène et d'autre part son
origine humaine alors que vous vous
rappelez je ne sa pas de nom que dans
les différents continents et la France
fait partie d'un de ces continents euh
il y a encore peu de temps ces
phénomènes étaient contestés ils ne le
sont plus contenu à la fois de la
profondeur des problèmes et de la
qualité des analyses qui ont été menées
par les scientifiques toutes les données
statistiques sont sans équivoque et bien
au-delà de la marge d'erreur que
ordinaire les scientifiques retiennent
quels sont les risques je vais pas les
énumérer tous mais je donnerai juste
quelques exemples puisque je crois qu'en
plus la presse nous fait l'amitié d'être
là le volume total des glaciers pourrait
être réduit de moitié voire de 80 %
d'ici à 2100 si rien n'est fait
l'augmentation du niveau de la mer
pourrait bouleverser nos côtes puisque
la mer pourrait monter de plus de 50 cm
d'ici la fin du siècle et jusqu'à près
d'un MRE selon les hypothèses les plus
pessimiste ceci je ne sais pas s'il faut
dire le conditionnel ou le futur
entraînerait des risques d'érosion et
d'inondation de plus en plus fréquent
sur les côtes où vit la majorité de la
population
mondiale ce qui
signifie évidemment les choses ne sont
pas aussi mécaniques mais il faut donner
des traductions concrètes d'un kerque
partiellement sous l'eau la Méditerranée
arrivant jusqu'à Arles et Rotterdam
devenu une île ceci n'est plus de la
science-fiction mais une hypothèse
malheureusement possible à la fin de ce
siècle si rien de suffisant n'est fait
d'autre part les changements climatiques
entraîneront aussi des risques accru sur
le secteur agricole qui pourrait
perturber la sécurité alimentaire
mondiale notamment les populations les
plus vulnérables que deviendrai les 40 %
de la population mondiale qui vivent de
l'agriculture si beaucoup de récoltes
sont amputées d'un/art à cause à la fois
de la chaleur et du manque d'eau
euh tout cela est fort bien résumé dans
les trois rapports qui ont déjà été
publiés par le GC et je voudrais faire
quelques observation à la lecture des
dernières conclusions du 5e rapport du
JEC qui nous apporte un diagnostic
scientifique clair et un état des lieux
préoccupant sur les possibles impacts en
particulier la baisse des rendements
agricoles l'élévation du niveau du mer
et la création de nouvelles poches
massives de
pauvreté d'ailleurs j'en tire une
conséquence qui va peut-être vous
paraître superficielle mais qui ne
l''est pas car les mots sont toujours
ant le mot de changement climatique qui
est souvent utilisé me paraît beaucoup
trop
neutre car après tout sans faire
référence à tel ou tel slogan politique
le changement est souvent perçu comme
positif et ce terme changement
climatique ne rend pas compte de la
gravité des risques je pré faire évoquer
pour ma part non plus le réchauffement
car scientifiquement ce n'est pas exact
les phénomènes à l'UVE se traduiront
parfois par des réchauffements parfois
par des refroississements le plus
souvent par des bouleversements
et pour toute une partie de la
population y compris la population
française euh évoquer la perspective
d'un réchauffement n'est pas après tout
nécessairement dramatique chacun au nord
de la Loire s'imaginant pouvoir vivre
sur la Côte d'Azur mais il s'agit
devenons sérieux de nouveau pas du tout
de ça il s'agit d'un drèglement
climatique euh en anglais climate
disruption qui exprime bien ce qui est
en jeu c'est-à-dire la capacité de
l'espèce humaine à se nourrir à se
développer à vivre décemment et même à
survivre c'est de cela qu'il s'agit donc
c'est pas simplement un changement
climatique et certains commencent même à
parler en anglais la présidente de la
convention climat parle de Global weness
c'est-à-dire d'étrangeté globale c'est
un phénomène de bizarrerie global si
nous restons inactifs nous allons léguer
à nos enfants un monde en rupture avec
celui que nous avons connu dangereux
évidemment
extrêmement difficile à vivre le trème
volet du rapport du GEC j'ai dit
quelques conclusion que je tiraai de ces
travaux qui été publiés il y a peu de
semaines montre à la fois la gravité de
ses conséquences du phénomène lui-même
et qu'il est encore temps
d'agir je prends comme exemple une des
Prin principale préconisation du
rapport un triplement voir un
quadruplement de la production d'énergie
sobre en
carbone certains pourraient y voir un
mal nécessaire mais dans un monde où les
coûts de ces sources d'énergie notamment
les renouvelables évoluent rapidement où
les conséquences des énergies fossiles
sur la santé sont de plus en plus
claires où l'innovation bas carbone
commence à réconcilier écologie économie
je vois et c'est une ligne directrice ce
que nous allons essayer de suivre dans
sa conférence de Paris j'y vois aussi
une chance à saisir c'est évidemment une
contrainte redoutable mais il y a aussi
une chance à
saisir un deuxième point sur lequel je
voudrais faire quelques remarques c'est
sur l'utilité la forme que pourrait
prendre l'accord climatique auquel nous
aspirons beaucoup de pays et de régions
commence à saisir à la fois la
contrainte et la chance d'ailleurs vous
savez peut-être que aussi bien en
chinois contemporain qu'en grec ancien
c'est le même mot qui signifie le risque
et la chance en chinois je ne sais pas
en grec ça s'appelle kindindunos c'est
le souvenir que j'ai de ma fréquentation
qui n'a pas laissé de trace apparente de
tucidide de de grands émetteurs mais
aussi de plus petits pays voi
aujourd'hui dans l'économie sobre en
carbone une voie alternative de
développement et la Chine qui n'est pas
la moins concernée contraire a fait de
ce qu'elle appelle la civilisation
écologique un de ces objectifs
explicites elle est devenue le premier
marché mondial pour les énergies
renouvelables aux États-Unis le plan
d'action du président Obama et on m'a
indiqué que président Obama devait
s'exprimer aujourd'hui je ne sais pas
siil va le faire sur cette question a
envoyé un signal fort vers les acteurs
locaux et privés le Brésil je cite
quelques pays particement important est
en voie de tenir son objectif de 80 % de
réduction de la déforestation entre 2005
et 2020 l'Islande le Costa Rica de
petites villes îles vulnérables comme
les Maldives se sont engagé sur la voie
de la neutralité carbone ce sont là
quelques exemples parmi beaucoup
d'autres mais au total déjà près d'une
centaine de pays ont pris des
engagements de réduction de leurs
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ces
engagements sont volontaires en dehors
du protocole de Kyoto mais il pose C
intéressant des jalons pour aller plus
loin collectivement l'enjeu d'un accord
à Paris d'un accord universel est de
fournir un cadre de mettre en place des
outils pour agir ensemble mieux et plus
vite et notamment parce que c'est un
point essentiel dans les négociations
d'aider les pays en développement à
s'adapter à s'engager sur la voie d'un
développement durable par les transferts
de technologies et la mise en place de
financement notamment à travers le fond
vert l'objectif pour Paris 2015 tel qu'
il a été fixé à Duban il y a 2 ans est
clair il doit s'agir d'un accord
applicable à tous juridiquement
contraignant et comportant des
engagements de réduction d'émissions
compatibles dans la durée avec un
réchauffement maximal de 2 degrés voilà
la commande générale ce sera si nous y
parvenons une première dans l'histoire
des négociations climatiques car
n'oublions pas que le protocole de Kyoto
est certes contraignant mais qui
concerne aujourd'hui à peine plus de 15
% des émissions mondiales et les
engagement volontaire de copenhag et de
Cancun concern un nombre important de
pays mais il n'y a pas de force
juridique ce qui évidemment les fragilis
depuis Durban nous commençons à forger
une vision collective de ce à quoi
pourrait ressembler un accord utile
premièrement cet accord serait d'abord
constitué d'un cadre robuste de règles
et de mécanismes pour garantir la
transparence sur sa mise en œuvre
c'est-à-dire garantir que les
engagements de Paris ne seront pas des
paroles en l'air et permettre un
renforcement une évolution dans le temps
des engagements nationaux deuxièmement à
côté de ce socle commun viendrai
s'ajouter les engagements de réduction
d'émissions déterminé nationalement il
nous semble que la flexibilité devrait
être une caractéristique clé qu'est-ce
que je veux dire nous n'agissons pas
pour la conclusion d'un accord parfait
sur papier et qui serait obsolète après
sa signature il faut que cet accord
puisse accueillir les engagements
successifs sans que l'on doive
renégocier l'ensemble car il y a un
suivi dans le temps à opérer
troisièmement enfin Paris doit être le
moment de cristallisation d'initiative
de partenariat d'engagement des
différents acteurs et par différents
acteurs il y a bien sûr les États mais
aussi les collectivités locales les
entreprise les ONG les fonds
d'investissement m bout à bout ces
initiatives montreront que l'action est
lancée que la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique est non seulement
possible mais souhaitable pour apporter
à nos société et nos économies à la fois
soutenabilité croissance et bien-être
dans ce cadre que jeadresse à grande
guide car il serait contradictoire de
vouloir jouer le rôle normal de la
présidence et en même temps de dire
voilà exactement où l'on va et voir
qu'une tête il y a une fonction de
synthèse à opérer qui doit être distinct
c'est un point très important de la
contribution de la France bien sûr la
France préside mais la France est aussi
une partie prenante et il ne faut pas
confondre les deux au risque évidemment
de poser un certain problème la
stratégie française quelle peut-être
quel doit être notre rôle en tant que
pays haute dans la conclusion
souhaitable de cet accord la première
priorité c'est l'exemplarité nationale
en ce début d'année il y a eu la
contribution climat énergie qui est un
pas la loi sur la transition énergétique
qui va vous être soumise avant l'été je
crois dans le calendrier parlementaire
devra nous mener plus loin vous aurez
vous un rôle essentiel dans la
construction et l'adoption de cette loi
qui doit être aussi ambitieuse que
possible car mieux nous agirons
nous-mêmes plus nous serons légitimes à
encourager d'autres à s'engager la
ministre de l'écologie et du
développement durable qui est
responsable pour la partie française
même si c'est moi-même qui préside la
conférence
évidemment mènera ce travail pour
devenir ce qu'elle appelle j'espère que
ce sera le cas la première puissance
écologique d'Europe et nous devons
tendre vers cela à la fois à cause de
notrere exemplaire et parce que la
compétitivité de la France est en jeu
mais au-delà de la France c'est l'Europe
dans son ensemble qui doit montrer ce
qu'est l'exemple et euh il faut à cet
égard euh souligner que c'est sur la
base d'une certaine transition
écologique que l'Europe a construit
durant plusieurs années un leadership
qui est assuré au sein des négociations
climatiques internationales et s'il n'y
avait pas ce leadership nous ne
pourrions même pas parler de
l'éventualité d'un accord mondial en
2015 nous devons jouer ce rôle
d'entraînement jusqu'à et au-delà et
concrètement ça veut dire que
malheureusement nous n'avons pas pu au
mois de mars aboutir à une décision
formelle de l'Union européenne alors que
la Commission avait fait des
propositions intéressante la France
souhaite très vivement que nous
parvenions à une conclusion précise au
maximum au mois de mai ou juin car
passer ce délai et cont tenu en plus du
remplacement de la Commission qui va
faire que des difficultés inévitables
vont être encourues nous risquerions en
tant qu'Européen de ne pas pouvoir
donner des indications aux autres si
nous ne sommes pas capables nous-mêmes
de prendre des décision ce qui veut dire
que dans notre stratégie diplomatique
vous mvez interrogé sur la diplomatie il
faut que s'agissant de la France et
s'agissant de notre impulsion auprès des
autres européens nous fassions le
maximum pour que cet accord au niveau
européen puisse être conclu si possible
au 1er semestre nous devons donc pas
laisser des désaccords internes
l'affaiblir l'Europe doit
poursuivre le découplage entre
croissance économique et trajectoire de
ses émissions de gaz à effet de ser la
France souhaite donc l'adoption la plus
rapide possible d'un cadre
énergie-climat robuste pour
2030 sur la base je l'ai indiqué il y a
un instant de la proposition de la
Commission européenne d'une réduction de
40 % de nos émission 2030 par rapport à
1990 en tant que future présidence nous
devront être des facilitateurs des
discussions globales sur le climat en
2014 c'estd cette année nous ne sommes
pas et nous devons pas être au tout
premier rang parce que l'actuelle
présidence polonaise et la future
présidence péévienne joue ce rôle il y
aura vous savez à Lima au mois de
décembre l'équivalent mais non conclusif
de ce que sera Paris climat 2015 mais
même si nous vons accompagner ce
mouvement sans le diriger nous forgeons
dès aujourd'hui notre méthode
c'est-à-dire une présidence qui veut
être offensive mais qui a besoin
d'écouter qui doit savoir convaincre
mais qui commencera par comprendre et
qui ne veut pas de consensus artificiel
le multiratisme est évidemment
fondamental et c'est ce qui nous
inspirera pour construire la confiance
pourfir ir le moment venu faire adopter
un accord et donc il faut le pratiquer
en dehors du cadre strict des
négociations nous devrons aussi à la
construction d'un élan politique fort au
plus haut niveau d'ors et déjà c'est la
raison de ma présidence j'ai mobilisé
toutes nos ressources diplomatiques et à
chaque rencontre bilatérale ou
multilatérale qui se produit et à
laquelle je participe ou les secrétaires
d'État à chaque réunion du G7 ou du G20
nous plaçons le climat à l'ordre du jour
notre objectif c'est que l'enjeu
climatique prenne la place de premier
plan qui doit être la sienne dans les
priorités de nos
interlocuteurs une autre orientation de
notre action
est de faire que ce soit une action
positive François mitteran utilisait
souvent une formule qui me faisait
sourire il disait si vous dites
aujourd'hui c'est difficile demain c'est
pire et je ne vous parle pas
d'après-demain mieux vaut choisir une
autre fonction et je pense qu'il avait
raison il s'appliquait à la politique en
général étant un expert de cette matière
mais si nous revenons à notre sujet je
crois que sans dorer la pilule il faut
que nous expliquions que c'est à notre
portée sinon nos concitoyens vont se
désintérêts de l'objectif et des
inéressés et nous pourrons avancer nous
devons donc euh à la fois sur le plan
diplomatique susciter un certain nombre
de coalitions novatrices faire la preuve
par l'action mais aussi rassembler
mobiliser les
collectivités les entreprises les
acteurs étatiques et non étatiques sur
l'accès à l'énergie durable le transfert
de technologie la ville durable
l'agriculture le financement il y a déjà
des progrès par exemple j'étais à Davos
au début de l'année et euh deux très
grandes entreprises ise j'ai oublié la
seconde mais la première était Unilever
qui est vraiment un des grands grandes
entreprises mondiales et des grands
polluants mondial ont pris des
engagements notamment de ne pas utiliser
la forêt indument donc il y a un
mouvement qui est lancé davantage de ces
de ces entreprises étent regroupé à Abu
Dhabi au cours de ces derniers jours
elle vise à promouvoir l'énergie propre
en Afrique à conclure un Pact des mers
pour l'action climatique et vous avez vu
par exemple que bankimoun j'en dirai un
mot dans un instant qui est très
mobilisé sur ce sujet a désigné l'ancien
maire de New York monsieur Bloomberg
pourêtre son représentant pour vraiment
impliquer les collectivités locales et
c'est une excellente idée qu'il s'agisse
d'ailleurs de l'action climatique de
réduire les fuites de méthane et cetera
et ces coalitions nous devons en faire
une cartographie ce sont ces messieurs
qui en sont chargés je vais vous
expliquer dans un instant ce qu'ils font
et pour que les choses comme aurait dit
tard de Chardin convergent et que nous
puissions à condition que nous y
prenions rapidement le temps absolument
central dans cette affaire avoir à la
fois la pesée des états la pesée des
organisations international la pesée des
collectivités locales la pesée des
entreprises la pesée des ONG la pesée
des opinions publiques tout cela
convergeant vers l'objectif souhaitable
et l'un des temps forts il y a beaucoup
de temps forts c'est anné en permanence
il y a des conférences sur ce sujet
c'est très bien mais l'un des temps
forts va être le sommet de l'ONU sur le
climat que notre ami le secrétaire
général des Nations unies bankimoun va
accueillir à New York le 23 septembre
sera une date très importante car euh
nous essayons de faire en sorte avec
Bank kimoun que le maximum de leaders
mondiaux s'engage au nom de leur pays
car euh nous considérons que en
regardant ce qui a été fait à copenhag
et ce qui a été fait dans différentes
conférences il y a plusieurs erreurs à
éviter n'avons pas apportter jugement
critique sur telle ou telle conférence
mais essayer de tirer les leçons et
lorsque je suis allé à Varsovie la
dernière conférence j'ai posé à tous les
interlocuteurs que j'ai rencontré la
même question je j'avais pensé leur
poser la question mais comment fait-on
pour réussir mais je me suis dit ils
vont être très modestes et bon donc je
leur ai posé une question un peu
détournée qui plus intéressante Jeur dit
quelles erreurs ne faut-il pas commettre
et ils ont été très bavards à partir de
cette question et en particulier j'en ai
conclu deux choses parmi d'autres
premièrement il est essentiel que nous
ayons des engagements le plus vite
possible car la mise en musique de tout
cela demande beaucoup de temps et donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle à Varsovie
il a été dit que les différents pays
devaient prendre des engagements au
maximum au début de l'année prochaine
certains pays de ce point de vue-l dans
une situation difficile nos partens
Américains nous ont expliqué que contenu
des midterm election éétait pas possible
de et cetera mais il faut que le maximum
de pays s'engage et c'est là où la
journée de bankyon comme je l'appelle de
manière un petit peu familière est très
importante car si vous avez de grands
leaders mondiaux qui viennent à la
tribune des Nations Unies dire en ce qui
concerne mon pays voilà ce qui se passe
à ce momentl il est très difficile aux
autres de se cacher derrière le silence
général et parmi les pays dont j'espère
très très fortement qu'ils pourront
prendre un engagement il y a évidemment
la Chine président shissiping était
récemment à Paris pour une visite qui a
été à Lyon pour une visite très réussie
nous avons abordé avec le président
français ses sujet avec le président
chinois et à partir du moment où les
Chinois c'est un changement majeur par
rapport auparavant sont vraiment
convaincus qu'il doivent bouger cela a
une force
extraordinaire que le président
chissping ou le Premier ministre lit
viennne à la tribune des Nations Unies
pour dire voilà nous avons réfléchi
voilà notre engagement car il y a
évidemment d'autres pays qui n'ont pas
fait ce choix politique encore et donc
la première conclusion que j'ai tiré
c'est il faut que les engagements soient
rapide la deuxième conclusion que j'ai
tiré c'est que bien sûr les politiques
doivent s'engager c'est une affaire qui
au niveau de jacqu nation est décidé par
le président Premier ministre le
gouvernement mais on ne peut pas espérer
que ce soit au dernier moment que ces
responsables réunis en l'occurrence à
Paris résolvent la situation c'est ce
qui avait été tenté à copenhag moi je
n'y étais pas mais on m'a raconté cela
où au dernier moment la dernière nuit
peut-être quelques personnalité
remarquables se sont réunis euh dans un
coin ils étaient 4 5 6 je ne sais pas
ils ont élaboré un texte dont ils
pensaient que il allait être décisif ils
l'ont ramené devant l'assemblée générale
qui leura dit votre texte vous pouvez le
garder dans votre poche bon donc il faut
que les grands politiques s'investissent
au nom de leur pays tôt mais il faut que
le temps soit laissé ensuite aux
obstures techniciens que nous sommes
pour permettre de faire les synthèses
utiles et c'est par le va et vien entre
ces deux éléments qu'on peut espérer
dans cette matière extraordinairement
difficile trouver un accord d'autant que
je signale vous le savez parfaitement
que c'est un accord par consensus il fut
un temps je ne citerai personne qui
n'est pas très lointain ù l'issue de la
conférence le président de la conférence
avait demandé au participants à la
conférence que ceux qui sont pour VE
bien lever la
main que ceux qui sont contre veuent
bien lever la main personne n'est contre
c'est donc adopté bon mais ça je ne
pense pas que on puisse ni surtout qu'on
doiv le faire et donc le consensus doit
être réel ce qui a combien 180 et
quelques pays n'est pas d'une facilité
aveuglante c'est la raison pour laquelle
je dis tout ça en plaisantant lorsque la
France qui d'ailleurs était la seule
candidate a
obtenu cette conférence en général quand
on est seul candidat ça facilite quand
même la victoire ceux qui sont venus me
saluer m'ont dit dans un même souffle
félicitations et ils ajoutaient tout bas
condoléance donc j'ai j'oublie la
deuxème partie de la phrase je pense que
c'est une grande responsabilité une très
grande grand responsabilité pour la
France mais qu'il faut prendre les
dispositions pratiques pour essayer de
mettre tous nos atouts tous les atouts
de nos côtés et de ce point de vue-là
l'engagement personnel et très fort du
secrétairegénéral bankimoun est quelque
chose de évidemment très important ces
initiatives des uns et des autres des
nations des organisations des
collectivités de l'ONU et cetera doivent
constituer la rampe de lancement du
futur accord et créer un contexte
favorable au progrès de la négociation
politique quelques mots sur l'
implication de la société civile et sur
l'organisation matérielle de tout
cela la société civile dans son ensemble
a évidemment un rôle tout à fait majeur
à jouer pour peser positivement sur le
succès de la négociation entre état
c'est notamment pourquoi sur le plan
logistique nous mettons en œuvre le
maximum pour créer les meilleures
conditions possibles d'accueil et
d'accessibilité en direction de la
société civile et aussi bien sûr des
médiases
feront beaucoup ils ont commencé
d'ailleurs pour assurer la visibilité de
cet événement qui devra aussi être
exemplaire du point de vue de l'impact
environnemental et nous a-t-il semblé de
l'implication des citoyens puisque ça
aura Liu au Bourget même si s'appelle
Paris c'est au Bourget et du département
de la scène saint le rôle de la société
civile en décembre 2015 ne va pas se
limité aux 2 semaines de la COP il y a
énormément à faire d'ici là les
parlementaires et plus particulirement
les sénateurs peuvent aider nos efforts
français de plusieurs façons tout à
l'heure je parlais de l'exemplarité
français sur le climat j'attire
notamment votre attention sur la
ratification de la deuxième période
d'engagement du protocole de Kyoto qui
va vous être transmise prochainement et
sur laquelle la France et l'Union
européenne sont attendus d'autre part il
existe un potentiel de mobilisation des
collectivités territoriales que vous
représentez particulièrement autour de
l'enjeu climatique comme l'a indiqué le
rapport desén ur DC et delb je salue
l'un de ces jumeaux puisque maintenant
l'un ne peut pasêre citer sans l'autre
plus de la moitié des émissions
mondiales sont liées c'est ce que disent
nos deux amis sénateurs à des décisions
prises localement l'échelle
internationale est la meilleure échelle
pour créer une impulsion politique et
des outils mais l'échelle locale dis-il
est la meilleure pour les mettre en
œuvre donc là le Sénat les sénateurs ont
un rôle tout à fait important à jouer
enfin les parlementaires peuvent et
doivent remplir une fonction de
facilitateur dans les négociations
internationales là aussi j'emprunte le
terme de facilitateur au rapport de
monsieurs Dantec et gelb par des
échanges au sein de groupe d'amitié par
vos participation au COP au sein de la
délégation française par les coalitions
internationales de parlementaires autour
du climat vous pouvez et j'espère vous
allez contribuer à la préparation des
décisions prises par les législateurs
nationaux pour beaucoup oup de pays la
préparation des contributions nationales
à l'accord 2015 va faire l'objet d'une
sanction législative il faut garder
aussi à l'esprit qu'au lendemain de la
cop21 c'est à ce niveau parlementaire
que tout se jouera pour que l'accord ne
reste pas lettre morte donc qu' prenne
les choses en amont en aval ou au milieu
vous avez vraiment un rôle très
important à jouer et connaissant la
sensibilité du du Sénat tout gros
profondu là-dessus je je sais que vous
le jouz voilà quelques éléments sur
notre démarche et nos attentes pour la
COP 21 je veux dire en je terminerai par
là quelques aspects matériels alors
comment travaille-t-on en interne si je
puis dire
euh à partir des indications données par
président de la République et le Premier
ministre
euh il y a essentiellement deux trois
secteurs ministériel qui sont mobilisés
bon d'abord le Kedor puisquil a été
choisi pour avoir la présidence au nom
de notre réseau diplomatique bon c'est
de ça qu'il s'agit et évidemment en tant
que patron du ké d'oret je mobilise tous
nos ambassadeurs au cours de cette année
de l'année prochaine sur cet objectif et
par exemple vous savez sans doute que se
réunit la conférence des ambassadeurs à
la fin du mois d'août chaque année et
l'un des thèmes centraux sera comment on
prépare la COP 21 parce que nous avons
le 3è réseau diplomatique du monde et si
chaque ambassadeur fait son travail et à
chaque fois que les sujets sont pososé
ajoute ce sujet-là c'est un un comment
dire phénomène positif euh qui qui euh
se développe et dont nous avons
absolument besoin euh le euh la ministre
de
l'écologie mène la délégation française
parce qu'il faut qu'il y ait une action
française donc j'ai dit qu'elle doit
être exemplaire et elle doit aussi en
liaison avec le qu d'orset joue un rôle
au sein de la démarche européenne et
puis euh madame jérardin qui est
secrétaire d'État chargé du
développement qui a pris la suite de
monsieur campfin va aussi intervenir sur
Cees sujets ainsi que quelques
personnalités j'en cite deux qui sont là
d'une part l'ambassadeur Lapouge qui est
ici qui est grand spécialiste de ces
questions et qui va coordonner notre
travail là-dessus dans la négociation
proprement dite qui est épouvantablement
technique et d'utre part monsieur
Guignard qui est le secrétaire général
qui s'occupe en particulier de
l'organisation matérielle de tout c
parce que c'est absolument colossal je
vous ai dit enfin j'ai cité ce chiffre
je crois 20000
délégué donc là plus tous ceux qui
voudront se rajouter c'est un événement
qui matériellement est très très
complexe à organiser donc nous avons
commencé à travailler
là-dessus y a à peu près un an je
crois évidemment nous sommes nous devons
être remplir uniquement notre rôle ne
sommes pas encore les présidents en
titre puisque il faut travailler avec
nos voisins et amis pérouviens polonais
et cetera ça se passe bien et au plan
interne j'ai le plaisir de réunir à peu
près chaque mois chaque mois et demi ce
qu'on appelle dans un jargon horrible
copile je crois que ça veut dire comité
de pilotage vous avez des copiles chacun
chez vous et autour de la COP 21 et donc
euh autour de de la table ok sont réunis
à la fois les ministres et leurs
directeurs compétents an et puis un
certain nombre de spécialistes que je
veux pas compromettre en citant tous
leur nom mais notre amiek est là et un
certain nombre de grands spécialistes du
climat et puis il y a aussi monsieur
HULLOT qui est le représentant du
président de la République et puis
madame marieen Aubert enfin tous ceux
qui un titre ou un autre ont un rôle
administrativo politique sont là pour
que disons les les choses soient bien
accordé et pour le moment les disputes
n'ont pas franchi les murs du kedorsen
ça se passe extrêmement bien d'ailleurs
si ça se passait pas bien au korcel
vraiment ce serait à désespéré non le
travail avance bien il faut que nous
fassions vraiment un travail de
préparation très très très précis parce
que c'est très très compliqué ces
affaires et en même temps que nous
nutrepassions pas notre rôle parce qu'il
faut pas croire que la présidence c'est
elle qui va donner le là et dire c'est
comme C c'est comme ça car il y a toute
une série d'organisations ADP et cetera
enfin les sigles euh florissent au fur
et à mesure que les jours passent euh
qui qui sont là et il faut plutôt être
facilitateur synthétiseur euh plutôt que
Grand Architecte de l'Univers c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe euh donc voilà
l'organisation matérielle alors
évidemment il y a des aspects financiers
il y a des aspects politiques il y a
toute une série de présences à organiser
euh et nous avons euh nous n'avons pas
perdu de temps mais il y a pas de temps
à perdre là nous sommes au mois de mai
il y a toute une série de conférences là
qui ont lieu en ce moment il va un grand
événement qui va au mois de juillet à
Paris à portée économique ensuite on va
se projeter dans le sommet de batkimou
de septembre ensuite directement vers la
COP de Lima au Pérou préparé par une
COP préparatoire au Venezuela quelques
semaines auparavant et puis on saute
directement dans l'année 2015 à Lima
normalement
il devrait y avoir un ours bien ou mal
léché je ne sais pas qui soit un premier
épuche de texte ensuite nous demandons
au pays de prendre des positions
nationales petit à petit l'accord
converge il faut que nousous occupions
très précisément des mesure de
financement il y aura certainement des
questions là-dessus parce que beaucoup
de pays nous disent ils ont tout à fait
raison c'est très bien votre affaire
mais comment financer moi je suis un
pays en développement je n'ai pas les
moyens donc c'est l'affaire du fond vert
c'est tout ça et il faut mettre dans le
coup
tous ceux qui peuvent financer euh et
puis il y a une cartographie politique à
bâtir pour que ceux qui sont les plus
réticents veuillent bien au fur à mesure
abandonner leur réticence alors
certaines réticences sont
compréhensibles on pense aux petites
îles à d'autres qui n'ont pas les mêmes
enjeux parce que eux c'est la vie ou la
mort d'autres ce sont des réticences
liées à leur niveau de développement à
leur manque de moyens financiers
d'autres ce sont des résistances
politiques car il y a quelques pays qui
disent non euh non non bah voilà euh bon
le problème existe mais enfin après tout
chacun chez soi et donc c'est il faut
mettre en en synergie tout cela et euh
faire en sorte rien n'est acquis que euh
en ce mois de décembre 2015 nous
puissions enregistrer euh un succès
voilà quelques éléments mais à vot
disposition pour des réponses plus
précises je réfléchissais à cela le mot
COP 21 bon c'est un peu mystérieux hein
on se demande quelle est la société
secrète COP 21 bon et en fait 21 c'est
parce qu'il y a eu 20 conférences avant
si j'ai bien compris mais c'est aussi
significatif que ce soit le 21 du 21e
siècle et donc il faut que petit à petit
euh dans l'opinion et on doit s'appuyer
sur les opinions publiques notamment les
opinions jeunes des des des jeunes nous
nous accréditions l'idée légitime que
c'est une responsabilité internationale
absolument massive que il s'agit pas
d'une conférence comme une autre où on
discute de modalités il s'agit àprement
parler de la condition de la possibilité
d'existence de la vie humaine et je
pense que si nous arrivons à cela sans
sur valoriser nos mérites euh c'est un
thème que je développe souvent quand je
parle politique avec les dirigeants que
je rencontre ça donne de la politique
peut-être une idée un peu différente et
peut-être un peu meilleure que celle qui
nous est souvent reprochée on nous dit
oui mais la politique c'est quelque
chose d'obscur d'un petit peu crapot oui
mais là il s'agit vraiment de préparer
le futur et il s'agit pas d'intérêt
égoïste ni égoïste d'un point de vue
national ni égoïste d'un point de vue
temporel il s'agit que le politique avec
un grand en paix retrouve ses droits qui
est faire en sorte que la vie en société
sur la terre soit possible et soit
meilleur et je pense que c'est un
élément qui peut si nous réussissons
faire regagner du crédit aux politiques
en général voilà Monsieur les Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs ce
que je voulais vous dire en quelques
mots c'est un défi très difficile mais
avec l'aide du Sénat rien n'est
impossible bien ministre merci merci
pour cette excellente exposé alors les
questions donc les premières questions
Monsieur Marcel denux ronand DC michel
Teston Yv
ROM et Louis Nigre voilà al on va
commencer donc par Monsieur Marcel
Deneux oui ça tombe bien monsieur le
ministre merci de votre exposé vous avez
campé descs moi j'avoue que je partage
votre constat et rien ne me choque dans
ce que vous avez dit ni par les
cheminements à venir alors je voudrais
vous faire part d'une partie de mon
expérience qui n'est pas grande pierre
mais j'apporte ma pierre à
l'édifice en
2001 2002 j'ai fait le premier rapport
sur les évolutions climatiques dans le
cadre de l'Office Parlementaire des
évaluations technologiques et j'ai à ce
titre là eu la chance d'être dans la
délégation parlementaire qui était allé
à Johannesbourg et je vous dis ça pour
que nos amis comprennent l'ambiance de
l'époque j'ai participé j'ai assisté
dans la même
salle à ce discours dont on parle la
maison Bru et vous regardons ailleurs le
matin et l'après-midi dans la même salle
le même auditoire a sifflé leur
présentant des US c'était l'époque où le
président des USA on vivait en encore
sur cette grande déclaration le mode de
vie des Américains n'est pas négociable
c'était cette époque il y a 15 ans bon
alors je vous dis ça et j'ai mesuré ce
soir-là la difficulté de mettre d'accord
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale je me suis dit on a quand
même beaucoup de choses qui nous
séparent comment va-t-on faire alors
vous ayant dit çaa Mo dans ce que vous
avez dit il y a des choses que je veux
appuyer et
rappeler nous avons beaucoup de chance
d'être la France pour l'organisation de
cette réunion internationale parce que
on ne le dit pas assez la France est
plutôt vertueuse dans ce système et nous
avons une crédibilité réelle s'il
fallait le chiffrer qu sont les éléments
de chiffrage les meilleurs pour
apprécier en matière de de production de
CO2 par habitant la France c'est 5
tonnes 8 moi je travaille beaucoup en ce
moment les affaires d'énergie avec
l'Allemagne l'Allemagne c'est 9 tonnes
et la moyenne européenne elle est
quelque part dans ces niveaux-là donc la
France a une base de de départ très
crédible pour être ceux qui organisent
et qui peuvent dans une certaine mesure
montrer le chemin vertueux et le dire
c'est à notre portée ce que vous avez
firmé il faut le dire c'est à notre
portée alors ayant dit cela comment on
chemine moi je partage tous les points
de vue je ne serai plus parlementaire
l'année prochaine mais je continuerai a
participer à mon niveau mais la question
que je voudrais vous poser c'est comment
allons-nous nous servir du
multilatéralisme avec l'expérience des
négociations diplomatiques que vous avez
et qui a manqué à Copenhague moi j'étais
à copenhag en fait nous n'avons pas eu
l'expérience de la négociation
diplomatique pour 36 raisons
d'organisation local et même de
participation française il était
difficile d'aboutir au bout de 2 jours
on en était conscient alors comment
mettrez-vous au service du système votre
habitude de la négociation diplomatique
et puis une question plus précise
comment comptez-vous vous servir des 700
millions d'habitants qui composent
l'Union pour la Méditerranée qui se sont
réunis fin janvier qui doivent encore se
réunir à a ce mois-ci autant que je
sache et qui sont porteurs d'un avenir
dans la mesure où leur existence à eux
est tout à fait mise en cause parce
qu'il se prépare en matière de
réchauffement climatique étant donné que
la France est quelque part dans la
situation d'un pays charnière dans cette
affaire autrement dit il y a là avec
uneion pour la Méditerranée votre compét
des négociations diplomatiques un levier
dont il faut se
servir
alors Monsieur ronand dc si on peut
monsieur le ministre n'aura pas le temps
de répondre à toutes les questions Chun
ne fait pas un petit effort donc
monsieur Rand oui donc pour pour être
rapide mais je crois que la présentation
de Laurent Febus était extrêmement clair
sur les sur les objectifs de la France
et sur sur
l'analyse peut-être juste en complément
puisque il se trouve que j'ai atterri
d'Abou Dhabi à 15h donc je je reviens
avec justement un petit peu le le
feeling de de ce qui s'est passé à Abu
Dhabi je crois qu' est important de
comprendre que collectivement peut-être
pas de manière consensuelle mais assez
majoritairement l'ensemble des acteurs
ne pas reviv Copenhague ça je crois que
c'est extrêmement clair et que il y a un
sentiment partagé qui est que finalement
le succès de Paris c'est que au
lendemain de Paris les acteurs sont en
mouvement puisque aujourd'hui je crois
comme Laurent Fabius l'a très bien dit
le le climatoscepticisme est en train de
de battre en retraite et
scientifiquement démontrer l'origine
humaine mais il y a un espèce de
climatofatalisme qui a remplacé sur le
fait que finalement l'effort est tel que
il n'est pas accessible et que du coup
on peut peut-être se replier les uns les
autres sur sur son territoire ce qui
serait la pire des choses et donc il
faut absolument que l'EN main de la COP
et c'est la responsabilité de la France
l'ensemble des acteurs du citoyen à la
multinationale soit en mouvement avec
l'idée que c'est accessible dans le
courant du du du 21e siècle donc je
crois que c'est ce que Banky Moon
porte avec le sommet de de septembre
pour information donc moi j'ai présenté
avec les les représentant des autres
réseaux mondiaux le le compact of mayor
qui complète assez bien la nomination de
blondberg et on essaie de présenter à
New York finalement un tonnage agrégé de
l'ensemble des actions des des des
villes mais pas que des grandes je crois
que c'est important de de montrer que ce
sont tous les territoires qui sont en
mouvement et ma ma remarque peut-être
pour être justement rapide c'est que
j'ai aussi assisté à l'atelier finance
et ce qui est quand même assez marquant
c'est dans le propos de de Christina
Figueres que la la question du fond vert
reste quand même assez central
aujourd'hui sur le fait que si les pays
développés ne tiennent pas l'engagement
de Copenhague l'un des rares engagements
de Copenhague alors euh il sera
difficile de de créer la confiance s
lequelle il peut pas y avoir d'accord ce
qui veut dire je me retourne un peu
finalement vers les uns et les autres
puceque Laurent Fabius a un peu
interpellé les parlementaires qui est
que demain si nous voulons l'accord il
nous faudra aussi faire un effort
financier direct ou indirect et qu'il
faudrait pas que demain tous ceux qui se
disent le climat c'est extrêmement
important finalement rechigne au moment
où il faudra quand même sortir d'une
manière ou d'une autre le le carnet de
chèque je crois que ça c'est un enjeu
majeur il faut être conscient que si
nous ne tenons pas la promesse de
Copenhague nous ne créerons pas la la
dynamique à Paris en 2 en 2000 15 merci
Monsieur michel Teston merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre et ancien
Premier ministre je souhaite vous poser
brièvement deux questions elle pte sur
le positionnement de l'Union européenne
de la Chine au cours de la
conférence il me paraît absolument
nécessaire que l'Union européenne parle
d'une seule et même voix au cours de la
conférence donc ma question est simple
comment l'Union européenne se
prépare-t-elle et de quelle manière on
peut penser en effet que certains États
européens qui sont effectivement
intéressés par l'exploitation de leurs
ressources fossiles n'auront peut-être
pas la même position que d'autres et la
deuxème question on a entendu que le
président chinois vous vous l'avez
d'ailleurs cité dans votre
intervention annoncé des réformes
économiques et qui consisteraiit à
partir les bénéfices finalement du
développement plus équitablement tout en
diminuant la pollution est-ce que ça
peut se traduire lors de la conférence
par un changement du discours
diplomatique chinois ce qui serait
absolument nécessaire
oui très rapidement monsieur le ministre
j'ai été particulièrement sensible aux
arguments que vous avez développé pour
témoigner de l'importance de cette
conférence en appelant d'ailleurs à un
élan politique fort à des engagements
plus rapide possible je considère que la
France a un rôle central et vous l'avez
bien compris a joué dans cette dimension
si particulière pour le devenir de
l'humanité toutefois en revenant à des
considérations beaucoup plus bassement
matérialistes et filant la la question
de mon collègue Teston sur la capacité
de l'Union européenne à agir plus
collectivement j'ai la prétention de
considérer qu'aujourd'hui sur le
territoire national des collectivités
territoriales ont manifesté des des
intentions très fortes dans la
réalisation d'équipements structurants
qui permettraiit d'abaisser
significativement l'empreinte carbone et
je pense plus particulièrement un grand
projet qui peut concerner jusqu'à
l'ouest de notre pays je pense au canal
cnord europeope ne serait-il pas
judicieux en amont de cette conférence
que la nation française accompagnée par
les décisions que l'Europe a déjà arrêté
dans le cadre du financement de cette
infrastructure les collectivités
territoriales ayant déjà TM t moigner de
leur intérêt et de leur cofinancement
sur cette structure une décision
positive puisse être annoncée pour
montrer en la matière l'exemplarité de
la nation française qui serait une bonne
manière d'accueillir les autres
continents pour la réussite de ce Paris
climat 2015 merci Monsieur Madame Hélène
connaet
mon merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le le ministre tout d'abord vous
féliciter de vous être saisi d'un d'un
sujet aussi vaste c'est un acte
courageux non pas parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup de de concurrents puisque la
France était le seul pays mais au vu des
enjeux à à relever et puis aussi au vu
des des réticences peut-être que nous
voyons de la mise en œuvre des objectifs
qui avaiit été dessinés lors des
conférences précédentes et réticence
donc de mise en œuvre de de ceci ma
question va porter simplement sur le
financement de de la conférence je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il est très important de
sensibiliser le le plus grand nombre
nous avons besoin de travailler dans la
la transparence et au vu de du climat
économique que nous connaissons même si
les enjeux sont importants de pouvoir
sensibiliser le le plus grand nombre et
donc de savoir comment cette conférence
sera
financée merci Monsieur Yve podzo di
Borgo oui monsieur le ministre avvez
commencé votre intervention en faisant
allusion au aux grande masse GL qui
fonde et récemment avec le groupe
d'amitié arctique Antarctique é TER
australe du Sénat et la Fondation le
canué que je préside nous avons organisé
un colloque sur l'article et où
notamment nous avons une une
intervention très forte de Michel Rocard
qui s'inquiétait du fait que les 8 pay
les h pays riverins en fait bloquer les
choses et que l'article comme
l'Antarctique d'ailleurs était qui était
en fait surtout l'Artic puis qu'on av
paré de l'Arctique qui était quand même
un des éléments de cet changement
climatique était en fait aux mains de H
pays et que c'était pas ouvert alors la
question que je je vous pose c'est de
savoir dans quelle mesure alors je sais
qu'il y a un rapport de notre collègue
gâolin là-dessus qui vait sortir au
Sénat je veis savoir quelles sont les
mesures éventuellement qui pour être
envisagé durant cette conférence merci
Madame
leilla merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
monsieur le Président euh je voulais
apporter
quelques précisions s'il vous plaît par
rapport à votre à votre exposé j'ai le
14 février dernier organisé au sein de
du Sénat un débat sur l'Europe de la
défense autour de du Livre vert de la
défense des écologistes qui porte le
concept de Green defense dans lequel
nous nous abordons évidemment les les
sujets de problématique environnemental
de prévention des conflits d'accès aux
matières premières et évidemment du
dérèglement climatique donc avec un
prisme euh évidemment environnemental et
également avec une approche de défense
sur ce sujet contte tenu du fait que
précisément en ce qui concerne notre
notre défense est la première emprise
foncière et qu'une transition
environnementale et et énergétique ne
peut pas se faire sans l'armée et que à
titre d'exemple l'armée améri américaine
consomme à peu près 360000 barils de
pétrole par jour à savoir plus de la
consommation journalière de la Suède euh
le Secrétaire Général des Nations Unis
monsieur ben kimoun reconnaît lui-même
que le dérèglement climatique est une
donnée enfin est un risque majeur
stratégique et nous même dans le Livre
vert de la défense des écologistes nous
considérons que le dérèglement
climatique doit être intégré comme une
donnée stratégique pour notre défense et
de construire tout le sujet de la
défense et la construction de notre de
notre outil militaire autour de ce de ce
sujet éminemment important pour les
décennies à venir je voudrais avoir
votre sentiment monsieur le ministre sur
la manière dont vous abordez ce sujet du
dérèglement climatique en lien
évidemment avec les conflits
environnementaux et une des
recommandations que nous avons fait dans
le cadre de notre livre justement c'est
dans le cadre du COP 21 d'intégrer et
d'organiser une réunion des ministres de
la Défense cont tenu du fait
qu'indépendamment du fait qu'ils soient
ou non écologistes leur propres
contraintes d'organisation interne de
par le fait qu'ils consomme beaucoup
d'énergie ils sont soumis à à ces
contraintes donc je voulais également
avoir votre sentiment puisque ça fait
partie de la première recommandation du
Livre vert donc d'organiser en 2015 à
Paris une réunion des ministres de la
Défense autour du dérèglement climatique
comme une donnée stratégique pour nos
armées je vous remercie merci Monsieur
Louis
monsieur le ministre merci de votre
exposé liminire qui était
particulièrement intéressant et qui
mettait bien l'accent sur ce qu'il
fallait examiner aujourd'hui alors
pensée globale agir localement vous avez
dit la France doit être exemplaire je
vous rejoins assez facilement sur ce
point-là et plutôt qu'une question
j'aurais deux propositions à vous faire
la la première c'est de d'avoir une
politique plus pédagogique à l'égard du
grand public parce que nous n'arriverons
pas à avancer si le grand public lui
n'est pas convaincu de la nécessité
d'agir et je reprends donc la la FP de
15h qui annonce le fameux discours
d'Obama et Obama va utiliser la route
numéro 1 en Louisiane pour démontrer que
cette route est en train de s'enfoncer
et que ça va coûter 7,8 milliards
d'euros notamment au pétrolier pour
récupérer ça c'est quelque chose de
simple c'est quelque chose de concret
c'est quelque chose que tout le monde
peut comprendre et donc je souhaiterais
qu'on soit plus pédagogue j'aborde le
problème non pas au niveau de la
conférence vous le voyez mais de manière
terre à terre par le petit bout de la
lorniette deuxème
proposition il faudrait intervenir
beaucoup plus fortement sur les
transports vous savez que les gaz à
effet de serre proviennent en grande
partie au moins 30 % des gaz donc des
transports et je suggère fortement
puisque la France a une position plutôt
en pointe dans le domaine du véhicule
électrique grâce notamment à deux choses
un mix qui est énergétique qui nous est
favorable et deuxièmement parce que
Renault constructeur mondial s'est lancé
là-dedans et bien je suggère fortement
au gouvernement je l'ai dit au ministre
du redressement productif je l'ai dit au
ministre donc de l'environnement et je
vous le dis je je suggère fortement que
le gouvernement a une action dans ce
domaine beaucoup plus forte qu'il ne l'a
actuellement pour faire en sorte que les
collectivités locales les flottes
d'entreprises les flottes de nos
communautés d'agglomération et davantage
voir les ministères et davantage de
véhicules électriques qui pourraient
servir d'exemple aux
autres madame Éveline Didier madame
Éveline
Didier excusez-moi monsieur le Président
euh merci Monsieur le Ministre de la
précision de votre de votre exposé et de
son exhaustivité
euh plusieurs questions ont trouvé
réponse à travers ce que vous avez dit
donc je ne m'en tiens là simplement
comment la question sociale est prise en
compte dans ce travail qui est fait pour
la préparation euh de Paris 2015 ça
c'est ma première question la deuxième
de grands pays jusqu'ici ont été très
réticents je pense notamment à l'Austral
au Canada est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
est raisonnable d'envisager que ils vont
rejoindre le concert des grandes nations
pour essayer de lutter contre le
réchauffement
climatique le fond vert effectivement
comme l'a dit Monsieur DC c'est c'est
quelque chose d'assez symbolique
pouvez-vous nous indiquer quelle est la
participation demandée à la
France et
enfin on parle de pédagogie mon collègue
citait quelques exemples moi je je
dirait que rien ne va pouvoir être gagné
sans les médias or les souvenirs que
j'ai des différentes conférences
précédentes les le le jeu médiatique a
consisté à à chercher toutes les fautes
que faisaient les parlementaires ou ou
les les membres du
gouvernement à l'extérieur on en a fait
une aventure politicienne alors même que
là comme dirait mon collègue Daniel
Renner le la maison brûle et et comment
faire en sorte que les médias soient à
la fois engagés et responsable dans
cette et et qu'il ne transforme pas ça
en en petite bisbille
médiatique Madame Chantal
Jouano bonjour monsieur le ministre
merci pour votre exposé j'ai eu la
malchance d'être à Copenhague et la
chance de ne pas y être comme politique
et donc d'avoir accès à peu près à à
tout et notamment aux négociations
préalable dans ce qui s'est passé à
copenhag c'est que la négociation
préalable des experts et diplomatiques a
échoué et qu'on est arrivé le jour où
les chef d'État entrer dans la
négociation avec un texte où il resta 90
points en
négociation l'échec était en partie dû à
des problèmes d'organisation et à
l'impossibilité de mettre autour de la
table les représentants du
G77 donc la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est serons-nous CAPA
d'éviter cette nouvelle
erreur de de procédure il semble que
l'évolution de la Chine comme vous
l'avez signalé soit plutôt favorable et
que le la volonté finalement de laisser
les acteurs prendre des engagements
volontaires et d'être moins exigant que
ce qu'il y avait à copenac soit aussi
plus
favorable mais qu'en est-il de notre
relation nous européens avec l'Afrique
parce qu'on a vu sur la conférence de
Nagoya sur un autre sujet qui était
difficile que la relation UE Afrique a
permis de faire aboutir cette conférence
est-ce qu'on une on a une action
particulière vis-à-vis de de l'Afrique
et d'autre part quel est votre sentiment
sur l'évolution du discours du Brésil
qui là aussi est par contre est
peut-être moins positif que ce qu'elle
était auparavant enfin bon je reprendrai
pas les les ce qui a été dit sur le fond
vert et que je partage par Monsieur DCH
et Madame Didier le dernier point sur
les collectivité qu'est-ce que vous
prévoyez pour les régions parce que
c'est vrai qu'on a vu que sur la plupart
des négociations elles ont un rôle très
proactif et beaucoup plus ambitieux que
la plupart des des
gouvernements ministre merci
beaucoup je regarde bon al on va aller
au Galot hein ah
madame Marie allez-y madame donc la
dernière allez-y madame monsieur le
ministre évidemment comme tous mes
collègues je vous remercie c'était un
exposé clair extrêmement pédagogique
j'admire surtout votre enthousiasme
parce que vous avez même dit que vous
enleviez le mot condoléance au mot
félicitation bravo mais peut-être que
malgré tout je ne le partage pas nous
avons auditionné il y a au mois de juin
dernier dans cette même commission
madame Connie ed degard qui est donc
commissaire européen au au climat et qui
a manifesté son inquiétude et qui nous a
même dit que l'incertitude quant au
résultat de cette conférence était un
cauchemar quotidien j'emploie les mots
qu'elle Ava employé à l'époque et elle
avait surtout évidemment invoqué les
problèmes économiques que qui qui
contrebalance évidemment le la volonté
de de respecter tout ce qui est
écologique et climatique alors je
voulais vous poser une question il y a
euh un certain nombre de personnes qui
se posent des problèmes concernant le
nouveau traité
transatlantique il paraîtrait et je
parle sous
votrement il paraîtrait que le
gouvernement serait prêt dans les
négociations actuelles à euh donné la
possibilité aux firmes
multinationales je je je prends les les
termes qui ont été employés hein
d'attaquer les états devant les
tribunaux si les réglementations
publiques faisaient obstacle à
l'investissement et au profit évidemment
si cela est exact et je vrais avoir
votre sentiment là-dessus serait un
véritable dumping écologique grave et
donc ça serait évidemment au niveau de
l'image de la France comme leader comme
vertueuse et comme exemplaire quelque
chose
d'inquiétant euh juste un mot euh pour
reprendre ce que dit mon collègue euh on
entend tout le temps au niveau
pédagogique dire la hauteur de l'eau de
50 à 1 m ce n'est absolument pas parlant
ce qui est parlant c'est de savoir
jusqu'où elle va dans les terres je
cétait juste parce que j'entends tout le
temps dernière question madame Joë garot
Mélan oui merci monsieur le Président
très rapidement vous nous avez demandé
en tant que sénateur d'être acteur de la
promotion de cette conférence nous le
serons bien évidemment mais je voudrais
souligner l'importance d'acteurs souvent
oubliés qui sont les Français de
l'étranger qui peut vous être très utile
dans ce domaine et je pense en
particulier au réseau de nos lycées
français à l'étranger où nous
scolarisons très souvent les enfants des
élites local et qui peuvent être un
moyen
insoupçonné de nous aider et en plus ces
enfants et leurs enseignants sont très
concernés sur cette question bon je
pense une initiative que je soutiens du
lycée de Milan avec en partenariat avec
le lycée du du Sénégal de Dakar parce
que vous savez que nous avons un énorme
problème de monter des à Saint-Louis du
Sénégal et je crois que là nous pouvons
vraiment fédérer beaucoup de bonne
volonté dans le monde
entier merci euh je remercie ceux qui
ont posé questions je remercie aussi
ceux qui ne l'ont pas posé euh parce que
le temps est limité donc j'espère que
vous m'excuserez
si je suis lacunaire euh cela n'est pas
dû seulement à mon incompétence mais
vraiment au manque de temps parce que je
veux pas être en retard pour pour la
suite de mon programme alors d'autant
que dans beaucoup de cas il s'agissait
de question et d'observation et qui qu'
n'y a pas à à commenter
euh monsieur denu a a souligné la
crédibilité de la
France et il a dit mais euh quelle
technique
diplomatique bon je ne suis pas un
diplommate de profession mais euh je
j'essaie de m'y mettre
euh mais vous
savez nous avons établi une espèce de
Cartographie
politique il y a des pays qui sont pour
employer un terme vulgaire très allant
d'autres qui sont plus réticents
d'autres qui sont très très réticent et
à partir de là nous essayons de bâtir
euh parce qu'on peut pas forcer un pays
qui ne veut pas quelles sont les
coalitions que nous pouons créer CR les
termes d'échange que nous pouvons
formuler nous le faisons j'en prends un
exemple au niveau européen dans un
instant nous essayons de le faire au
niveau mondial après c'est le jeu de la
discussion
et l'une d'entre vous disait mais vous
m'avez paru optimiste et Madame de garde
était plus pessimiste je ne suis pas
optimiste je suis volontariste et en
même temps je mesure l'immense
difficulté de cela si depuis des années
et des années les cops euh amènent
certaines évolutions parfois même
certains progrès mais non pas réussi euh
bon Zoro n'est pas dans cette salle en
tout cas je ne le connais pas mais il
faut avoir cet optimisme de la volonté
et de la nécessité ensuite mais je suis
incapable de vous dire avec 100 % de
chance que nous allons réussir en tout
cas nous devons être le maximum d'atout
de notre côté euh plusieurs d'entre vous
ont posé la question l'UPM l'Afrique
alors euh en l'UPM évidemment nous
allons essayer de de nous servir entre
guillemets de de de cette base commune
en ce qui concerne l'Afrique les choses
avancent assez bien je ne sais pas c'est
Madame Joanot notamment qui a fait cette
observation qui a posé cette question je
sais pas si vous avez l'occasion de de
jeter un œil sur les conclusions de la
réunion qui a eu lieu à l'Élysée en
décembre début décembre de de l'année
dernière où nous avons euh passer une
espèce d'accord avec l'ensemble de nos
amis africains puisque 51 pays étaient
là pour dire que nous allons aborder
ensemble ces questions évidemment le
travail n'est pas fini mais euh nous
avons trouvé c'est notamment monsieur
lapouche qui s'occupé de ça beaucoup de
de volonté de bonne volonté il est
évident qu'à partir du moment où nous
serons d'accord d'avoir une base commune
avec nos amis africains ça nous met en
beaucoup meilleure position pour parler
notamment avec le comp 77 et avec
d'autres et c'est un objectif qui nous
semble apporter demain simplement et
j'en viens immédiatement à cette
question qui revient dans plusieurs de
vos observations ils posent tous la
question du financement et ils ont
raison et
là-dessus nous savons que ce sera un
enjeu majeur pour l'adoption de
l'accord quel est l'état des discussions
et quel est l'engagement de la France
bon le financement va être clé pour la
conclusion de l'accord d'abord parce que
c'est un enjeu de confiance entre les
développés et les pays en développement
ensuite parce que objectivement la
transition mondiale vers unè un modèle
plus durable requier des investissements
conséquents en 2014 il y a deux enjeux
principaux premièrement la
capitalisation du fond vert il faut que
nous assuri une capitalisation initiale
ambitieuse du fond vert d'ici la fin de
cette année et
euh le fond maintenant il faut le rendre
opérationnel puisque la création a été
décidée il y a maintenant 4 ans et nous
allons
euh procéder à contribuer à cette
première capitalisation et nous y
affecterons une part significative des
revenus de la
TTF deuxièmement nous avons pris un
engagement collectif de dégager 100
milliards de dollars par an alors ça
peut paraître une somme énorme mais
quand on fait ces 100 milliards tout
tout compris y compris ce qu'apporte les
les ressources privées donc c'est à la
fois les ressources publiques et privées
d'ici à 2020 la capitalation du fond
vert va être un premier signal fort à
cet égard mais euh au-delà il faut que
les négociations prog sur les aspects
techniques notamment sur la création
d'un cadre transparent et harmonisé en
portage des flux financiers et l'accord
de 2015 va être clé pour parvenir à ces
100 milliards la somme peut paraître
énorme euh des travaux ont commencé qui
montre que c'est à notre portée euh et
je demanderais en particulier à une
personne que vous connaissez peut-être
qui est Madame Tubiana qui travaille
déjà à nos côtés qui est quelqu'un de
compétent et qui connaît bien ses sujets
de se pencher sur le côté financier et
l'agenda positif parce que c'est un
élément clé puisque je parle de
financement si j'ai compris madame
conouet qui qui malheureusement a dû
nous quitter elle posait aussi le
question de financement de la conférence
elle-même qui é une question différente
bon là nous sommes en train de de
travailler là-dessus c'est Monsieur
Guignard en particulier ici présent qui
s'en occupe ça dépend bien sûr du cahier
des charges des nations- Unies qui est
en cours de négociation parce que c'est
un élément important ça dépend du nombre
des participants ça dépend de concept
exact de la conférence et d'autre part
il faut que nous reflétions dans notre
organisation l'esprit de la conférence
c'est-à-dire
écoesponsabilité capacité d'innover une
certaine modestie et ensuite nous
programmons le le financement et nous
l'inscriront en PLF 2015 et 2016 bon il
faut voir aussi bon ça va coûter de
l'argent parce que quand on regarde les
précédents ça coûte de l'argent mais ça
c'est un investissement au sens le plus
noble que que fait la France il y aura
aussi sûrement des des retombées pour la
France parce que quand vous avez 20000
personnes officiellement qui viennent et
encore quelques dizaines de milliers
d'autres évidemment c'est pour la
capitale et pour l'ensemble de la région
un apport mais euh ne soyons
pas hypocrite ou ou ou ou miope il y a
un cût non négligeable à cette
conférence dès que les choses auront été
un peu précisées évidemment je vous en
informerai d'ailleurs je devrais me
rendre Bourget avec dès que les choses
auront un peu avancé pour expliquer à la
presse puis que plusieurs d'entre vous
on juste raison souigner l'importance de
la presse dans ce genre de de
rassemblement pour expliquer un peu où
nous en sommes alors Monsieur Dantec a
fait comme d'habitude des observations
pertinentes j'aime bien sa remarque
climatcepticisme non mais attention au
climatoofatalisme il faut faire
attention à ça monsieur Teston Union
européenne Chine mais la question étit
posée par
d'autres Union européenne les
propositions de la Commission sont
intéressantes même si on peut discuter
tel ou tel détail nous ne sommes pas
arrivés encore à un
accord notamment parce que quelques pays
ont des difficultés je pense
singulièrement à la Pologne vous avez vu
parce que la Pologne est très dépendante
de la Russie elle a des ressources en en
charbon qu'elle veut pas abandonner et
cetera il y a un pas non négligeable qui
a été fait il y a 2 TR jours de ça c'est
que le premier ministre Tusk a dit que
Contu de la situation en Ukraine il
fallait aller vers une politique
énergétique européenne et nous avons euh
emprunter le même mouvement même si à
l'intérieur de ce qui pense être la
politique énergétique européenne il y a
des discussions à voir notamment sur
l'aspect charbon
mais à quelque chose malheur est bon si
je peux dire même si on souhaiterait
éviter le malheur je sens chez mes
collègues par rapport à ce qu'on a connu
il y a 2 3 ans ou 5 ans ou 10 ans une
prise de conscience très très importante
de la nécessité d'avoir une politique
énergétique européenne avec trois
objectifs le premier c'est des coûts
plus bas le deuxième c'est la sécurité
d'approvisionnement et le trisème c'est
une politique qui soit compatible avec
les objectifs climatiques qui est pas du
tout le cas l'autre jour il y avait je
crois que c'était dans le monde un
article tout à fait remarquable de
Monsieur mestralet que vous connaissez
il disait en ma européen c'est un échec
absolument lamentable pu ce c'est très
cher la sécurité n'est pas assuré mais
en plus le produit de tout ce qui a été
fait c'est qu'il y a plus de charbon
qu'avant donc si on voulait un échec il
est là et
donc nous nous souhaitons nous allons
vraiment nous mobiliser pour faire
évoluer l'Union européenne dans le B
sens la Chine au moment même où c'était
il y a quelques
semaines les autorité décidit de faire
la circulation alternée vous avez ça en
tête bon parce que je crois il y avait
eu 10 % ou 20 % de dépassement du seuil
à Paris je me trouvais à Pékin où la
pollution était un multiple
18 multiple 18 pas 10 % ou 20 % multiple
18 du seuil autorisé et et par des
conversations aussi bien avec le
président chi que le premier ministre li
que beaucoup de d'amis ou de
collègues chinois c'est une vraie
préoccupation pour des raisons
sanitaires parce que bon il y a vraiment
des problèmes majeurs pour des raisons
économique parce
que il y a des cadres d'entreprises qui
ne veulent plus aller dans un certain
nombre de de de de villes chinoises
notamment à Pékin à cause de la
pollution et pour des raisons sociales
et politiques parce que la population
dit non et les dirigeants chinois sont
des gens très intelligents sensibles à
cela et donc
il ont décidé de faire évoluer les
choses c'est très compliqué Contu du
développement mais j'ai plaidé au
président auprès du président chi je je
retourne en Chine dans 10 jours et je le
referai auprès des autorités chinoises
pour que puisque la Chine a décidé et
c'est nécessaire c'est indispensable et
c'est sincère de faire cette évolution
et bien comme je le disais dans mon
propos introductif évidemment ça
changerait énormément la donne mondiale
si elle faisait l'annonce de cette
évolution et notamment au moment de la
conférence de Monsieur bankimoun et
c'est dans ce sens que nous travaillons
monsieur rom a posé la question
important du Canal C Nord Europe euh oui
mais il y a d'autres équipements aussi
mais évidemment il ne faut pas avoir une
contradiction entre les objectifs
généraux qu'on affiche et puis les
équipements qu'on fait ou qu'on ne fait
pas Madame Conway avait posé la question
du financement j'aiessayé d'y répondre
sur l'article oui vous avez tout à fait
raison monsieur Rocard est mon
représentant il est très très compétent
sur ces sujets et il est très
passionnant là-dessus c'est vrai que sa
thèse que je crois juste c'est que un
certain nombre de pays contrôlent ça
alors que quand on regarde non seulement
en terme climatiqu mais en termees
économique et
c'est région du monde qui concerne le
monde entier et donc la France a demandé
à pour associé à tout cela c'est un
sujet que nous avons présent à l'esprit
madame achie je dois dire avec grande
honnêteté j'espère que vous m'en
pardonnerez avant les 20 prochaines
années que je n'ai pas lu le le Livre
vert sur la défense ben c'est gentil
d'ailleurs je vois qu'il est blanc euh
mais en revanche votre idée euh est très
intéressante et je vais en parler mais
ce n'est pas une fin de N recevoir à mon
C le drant parce que c'est pas une
manière détournée de dire attention la
défense et faute mais ça concerne tous
les collègues qui ont des des des des
ministères décisifs et je pense que
serait très intéressant de montrer que
dans ce domaine aussi il y a des progrès
à faire ce qui si j'ai compris le test
de votre donc je suis preneur de de
donnez-moi ça monsieur Nère a parlé des
efforts de pédagogie tout à fait raison
et et
là nous n'avons pas encore suffisamment
avancé nous av'avons pas
pu parce qu'il y a des travaux à faire
des slogans enfin des exemples simples
c'est c'est babas mais nous allons nous
y mettre maintenant la même façon que
les transports il connaissent ça très
bien il sait aussi que en tant qu'ancien
président de l'agglomération ranaise
c'est un sujet que je connais assez bien
et sur l'électrique et donc si on peut
faire avancer les choses
excellent la question sociale
oui il faut non pas que qui dit social
dit comment dire attribution
préférentielle au syndicat mais il faut
que nous mettons toutes les forces y
compris les forces syndicales dans le
coup elles sont deandresse d'ailleurs il
faut le faire non seulement au niveau
européen mais au niveau mondial
Australie
Canada disons que en ce qui concerne
leur enthousiasme
écologique comment dire il y a encore
des marches de
progression l'Australie a changé de
gouvernement il y a quelques temps et le
nouveau Premier ministre conservateur a
fait campagne contre les taxes carbone
et
cetera au Canada il n'y a pas eu de
changement mais c'est une position
constante donc voilà vous savez sûrement
que l'Australie a la présidence du G20
là et nous avons demandé qu'elle
inscrive à l'ordre du jour si ntait pas
absolument spontané la question
climatique et auprès du Canada nous
allons devoir aussi faire effort nous
pas seul si les Américains bougent ça
entraînera quand même probablement aussi
les Canadiens mais disons que ça fait
paraître ça fait partie dans
notre comment dire
planisphère politique des pays qui
restent à convaincre pour employer une
formule neutre les médias bon je
rappellerai cette anecdote que j'avais
beaucoup aimé dans un livre du président
Pompidou euh consacré à sa vie enfin
livre de mémoire que j'avais lu un jour
comme ça et il avait dit quelque chose
donc c'était dans les années Pidou
c'était 70 bon qui n'a pas vieilli d'une
ride il raconte l'histoire suivante
euh madame Pompidou va inaugurer un
hôpital en Bretagne je crois à l'époque
il y avait encore l'ORTF bon et le la
station locale
de d'ortf envoie à l'époque il y avait
des télégrammes je crois télégram au
siège de l' RTF faut-il filmer madame
Pompidou et la réponse c'est filmer si
incident bon tout est dit tout est dit
voilà pas nous sommes pas pris une ride
bon donc ce que vous avez dit tel à côté
est plus intéressant que
hein que que que tel axe central bon
alors pasôler les médias ça n'a aucun
sens donc il faut que que les choses
soient organisées de manière telle que
comment dire même les aspects
majoritaires soient
intéressants so pas obligé d'aller sur
le petit côté des choses mais ça demande
beaucoup de réflexion beaucoup de
technique et donc il faut bien sûr si
nous voulons contribuer à la réussite
que cet aspect là soit aussi prise en
compte sans avoir en quoi que ce soit
l'illusion de contrôler les choses pas
question mais au moins donner aux médias
qui veulent faire objectivement leur
travail les occasions de le faire je
termine madame Joanot donc qui était à
Copenhague si je comprends bien donc son
expérience est très utile je vous ai dit
un mot sur europeafrique là c'est
quelque chose sur quoi il faut que nous
nous appuyons Brésil bon il se trouve
que mon nouveau collègue ministre
d'affaires étrangères et le négociateur
de Rio donc il connaît les choses
beaucoup beaucoup mieux que moi et ça se
voit quand je discute avec lui euh et
euh bon le Brésil a une position très
forte dans ce genre de conférence et en
même temps parfois un peu difficile à
cerner bon et donc nous allons faire le
maximum pour que le Brésil soit du côté
de la réussite voilà l'objectif que nous
pouvons essayer de nous fixer région oui
les régions quand je disais collectivité
local c'était les communes les régions
et cetera et nous allons
avoir est-ce que c'est cette année bon
en octobre il y a une espèce de de grand
union des régions où nous aurons le
plaisir d'accueillir monsieur schwar
seneger qui doit présider d'ailleurs ce
rassemblement puisqueque il a été je
crois qu'il n'est plus mais gouverneur
en Californie et euh mais il faut faire
flèche de tout bois hein euh mais je
compte beaucoup sur les régions parce
que souvent ce sont elles qui sont le
plus engagé et l'idée c'est que
collectivité diverses communes
départements région et cetera tout le
monde montre que il y a des résultats
euh positif lycée AF oui vous avez tout
à fait raison d'ailleurs j'ai demandé à
euh euh madame farno la la patronne de
la EFE de de et elle le fait elle m'a
dit que ça ça prenait très bien de de
mettre ces thématiques à l'ordre du jour
dans les différents lycées bon ça
intéresse beaucoup et du coup ça peut
diffuser dans les familles et auprès de
différents milieux dernier point
conyegarde et le traité transatlantique
bon euh conygard est une fille femme
très compétente malheureusement son
mandat à la Commission va terminer va se
terminer je sais pas par qui elle va
être remplacée ce sera important parce
que le rôle du commissaire est
important mais comme elle connaît le
sujet admirablement elle en connaît
aussi les difficultés non seulement au
niveau européen mais au niveau
mondial simplement elle bon elle mettra
son énergie au au service d'un succès
possible mais elle a raison de dire que
le succès n'est pas assuré le traité
transattique bon c'est un autre sujet
euh
dont dont vous aurez à
débattre parmi bon le traité
transatlantique je voyais des articles
de journaux aujourd'hui et puis à
l'approche des élections européennes
j'ai l'impression que on veut faire des
rapprochements qui d'ailleurs ne sont
pas illégitime et tel ou tel parti prend
position plutôt contre que pour je pas
beaucoup recensé de partis qui disent
oui quoi qu'il en soit moi j'ai vu ce
matin c'est le hasard des choses le
négociateur américain qui est à Paris et
et je lui dis ceci que je vous redis
écoutez cher Monsieur Nous nous abordons
ça sans préjuger bon quels sont les
objectifs les objectifs c'est si
possible pour l'Europe et pour la France
d'avoir un marché plus important de
faire en sorte que nous que nous
puissions vendre davantage de produits
agricoles davantage d'Appellation
d'Origine contrôlé que nous puissions
pénétrer davantage au marchés public de
chiffres je sais pas si sont exactes
c'est ceux qui figurent dans les Rapp
porort nous nos marchés publics
européens sont ouverts à 85
% les marchés publics américains avec
les régions
fédération à 20 % bon donc évidemment si
nous pouvions pénétrer ces marchés très
intéressant pour nous ça c'est les
objectifs les risques les risques c'est
ça se passe pas du tout comme ça les
risques c'est que alors que les
Américains ont accepter que
l'audiovisuel et ceetera soit en dehors
à un moment ils nous disent non les
risques c'est que des préférences
collectives que nous voulons maintenir
est un mot prétentieux pour dire que
nous voulons un poulet qui soit pas
frelaté nous voulons l'affaire des m et
cetera ne soit pas respecté le risque
c'est que sur les marchés publics les
États fédérés nous dire ah bah écoutez
on est désolé ça vous avez discuté avec
le centre mais vous nvez pas discuté
avec nous et nous on n'est pas d'accord
donc il y a à la fois des perspectives
il y a des risques il y a un problème
c'est celui auquel vous avez faire
allusion c'est quelle est l'instance
d'appel qui n'est pas encore décider il
faut choisir une instance qui ne soit
enfin qui soit objective et qui ne nous
mette pas dans de difficultés et il y a
un autre aspect qui est bon on comprend
bien que certains aspects de la
négociation puiss être secret mais moi
j'ai dit et je l'ai dit ce matin ou non
j'ai pas dit cet après-midi à
l'Assemblée mais ce matin dans groupe
dans lequel je participais le
gouvernement viendra tout les 3 mois
devant l'Assemblée devant le Sénat pour
dire voilà où nous en sommes puisque de
toutes les manières le négociateur
européen il y a une négociation tous les
3 mois bon s'il y a des choses secrètes
ben voilà on dira c'est secret mais sur
l'essentiel de la négociation je vois
pas pourquoi on ne dirait pas ce qui se
passe étanté qu'à la fin il faudra quand
même que vous disiez oui ou disiez non
bon moi je je par je pars pas avec une
idée préconçue si les objectifs peu-être
atteints que les risques sont écartés
bravo si les objectifs ne peuent pas ê
atteint et que les risques au contraire
adviennent ce sera non bon et on ne
parle pas en disant oh c'est merveilleux
parce que c'est américains ou oh c'est
horrible parce que c'est américains je
pense qu'il faut être très comment dire
bon français matofc on va regarder
honnêtement bon j'ai discuté mais
c'était trop rapide avec le négociateur
américain puis j'avais vu toute une
série de notes au stade où j'en suis je
suis incapable de vous dire si
finalement ce sera oui ou ce sera non je
ne sais pas mais ça dépend de la
négociation elle-même sur le calendrier
ce que m'a dit le négociateur c'est que
il y a des élections de moyen terme aux
États-Unis à la fin fin de l'année donc
il est pas question qu'il y ait des
avancées significatives avant bon donc
si on peut avancer ce sera l'année
prochaine après ce que j'ai compris euh
bon eux souhaitent avancer mais ça
dépendra vraiment du contenu de la
négociation bon et je trouve par rapport
à telle ou telle position que je vois
autant dire quoi qu'il arrive ce sera
oui ça n'a pas de sens ça dépend du
contenu autant dire quoi qu'il arrive ce
sera non alors que les
États-Unis et et l'Europe ça fait quand
même quoi 40 % du commerce mondial donc
si on pouvait aller en avant et aller
chercher des points de croissance
pourquoi pas mais au stade où nous en
sommes je suis je je pense qu'il n'est
vraiment pas possible de dire voilà
quelle va être la sanction finale
sachant que la sanction finale même si
c'est un négociateur européen qui
discute il faut que nous soyons d'accord
à la fin donc nous pouvons dire oui ou
nous pouvons dire non voilà où nous en
sommes bien excusez-moi peut-être
d'avoir été trop court dans mes réponses
mais merci à vous c'est nous qui vous
remercions Monsieur
Merci voilà pour cette audition de
Laurent Fabius le ministre des Affaires
étrangères qui a donc été entendu par
les commissions du développement durable
et des Affaires étrangères sur la
préparation de la conférence de Paris
sur le climat en 2015 vous pouvez bien
sûr toujours voir et revoir toutes les
auditions sur notre site sur
publsenat.fr très bonne fin de journée
sur les chaînes
parlementaires